the Saints are not here at the Super
Bowl because of the play that you're
seeing on the screen right now on NBCSN
the hit buying a couch where we Coleman
on Tommy Lee Lewis
it was both pass interference and an
illegal hit to the head of a defenseless
player neither was called the Saints
have privately received an apology from
the NFL an acknowledgment from the NFL
and a mistake was made but here we are
eight days later the NFL still has not
acknowledged publicly that a mistake was
made Peter you did the research you
found between 15 and 30 occasions over
the last 15 years where the NFL has come
out and said Lee screwed up a call we'll
try to do better in the future in 2003
when Mike Pereira was the head of
officials the Giants lost to the 49ers
39 38 in a playoff game in San Francisco
right now
there was a missed call a badly missed
call it happened to be pass interference
on the last play of the game a botched
field goal of the box field goal attempt
we're rich soy Burt was an eligible
receiver Wright had come out as an
eligible receiver went out and he was
tackled yes and so Mike prayer admitted
that it was wrong now here's what
happened after that game it was 39 38
the Niners won there should have been
one and there should have been a none
time down at the end of that game so the
Giants could have kicked conceivably the
go-ahead winning field goal but they
didn't do that but what the league did
on Monday is they issued a 60 word mayor
Copa we were wrong there should have
been an untimed down and it didn't stop
Jim fossil from being furious but it was
the right thing to do this
administration led by Roger Goodell does
not know what to do in this situation
they know what to do but for some reason
they're hiding in their Park Avenue
fortress will not say anything and as of
right now haven't said anything in the 8
days since the game I'm sure he's gonna
say something some milk toasty thing on
- on Wednesday when he has what he
should have said something is the right
thing to do it you don't have to do it
but you are given the back of your hand
to everyone in the Gulf Coast of
Mississippi that place sold out that
stadium even though one
third of the population was gone after
Katrina their team stunk they responded
by selling out that Stadium wit and they
have not had an unsold game since then
even though they were shaky franchise at
the time that almost moved to San
Antonio they're now one of the best
franchises in the league and what thanks
do they get from the NFL for that
silence what do you think what see NFL's
logic and handling it this way like if
you had to put yourself in their shoes
why have they decided to go like zero
dark thirty here and not say anything
a Goodell doesn't care right B they
think it'll go away yeah
it's an attention to the siege mentality
that came from Ray Rice like yeah let's
just let it's us against them people are
challenging us we're gonna do it our way
and it's almost like the more people try
to draw them out the more determined
they are to dig in yeah stick to their
plan you know there's some times where
you just say as a leader of an
organization you know leadership is
standing up taking the bullets for your
organization I know right girls paid
whatever he is you know Roger Goodell
makes 100 times the amount of money that
al River on makes which you could say
and in my opinion al River on it during
the season is the second most important
league employee that there is he's the
one whose forward facing for all the
coaches all you know everybody talking
about the plays that happened during a
game and yet they have devalued that job
and as I wrote this morning you know if
they really want to get better in that
job here's what I would do I would offer
Dean blandina right left the job in part
because of money but not big part in
part because he was tired of being you
know getting the slings and arrows but
what happens if if the lead goes to
Blandino and said we'll give you a we'll
give you two million bucks this year to
come and do this job what would he say
maybe he'd say no but you could try it
keep keeper ever on you know you know
basically build up that department so
that you've got a better chance to be
right and it's not just at the top it's
all the officials all the way down go
ahead and make them full-time employees
they don't want to pay them they like
the fact that their lawyers and business
people on the side who get the large
chunk of their money doing something
else and you have someone whose
attention is deluded use them all year
around have simulations in different
Fitness
programs and have them ready to go the
fitness programs is something they
really have to do but but if you had
access to them 52 weeks out of the year
it wouldn't be an issue but I really do
believe Peter the more people like us
try to tell them they need to come out
and acknowledge this publicly they are
more determined to not do turtle
interesting SC go inside Roger Goodell
does on Wednesday your do you ever
remember call so egregious like in your
history and writing and everything no
especially not with this on the line
yeah the combination of the call itself
look calls are missed all the time yeah
but when it happened and on the stage it
happened in my 35 years I haven't seen
anything like this here's the closest
thing we may ever get to an
acknowledgement from the NFL it comes
from the legal filing that the NFL
submitted yesterday in the case that was
that was pursued down in New Orleans the
NFL parties do not dispute that they
have previously advised the Saints
including the club's head coach that one
or more penalties were mistakenly not
called late in the NFC Championship game
and that the NFL would like its
officials on the field to make these
calls yeah that may be the maximum
acknowledgment that we get but you know
what if you're gonna say that why not
just go the rest of the way yeah and say
hey everybody we're sorry we screwed it
up and we're committed to making it
better moving forward that's what people
want to hear we're committed to fixing
it going forward that's the thing that
Roger Goodell should have said we are
gonna spare no expense
no man-hours we are going to do
everything we can to make sure that our
officials are better not only in the
Super Bowl but on opening day 2019
that's what he should have said in his
statement
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports